hi everyone my name is dr christine
pascoe and i'm the vp of sales marketing
accelerated technology laboratories
today we're going to be talking about
the importance of data integrity
with lens as well as tools and best
practices
what does it really mean it deals with
consistency it deals with accuracy and
precision
it deals with having a audit trail for
changes to data
it deals with making sure that the data
is maintained in a state
that can be accessed in the future and
that the data hasn't changed
today we're going to be talking about
the vast amount of data that's generated
in in the united states this year 2020
it's estimated that 1.7 megabytes of
data
is going to be created every second for
every person on the planet
it's just mind-boggling the amount of
data that's generated
and that deals with the data around the
globe and if you focus on the analytical
laboratory the data acquisition in that
space is also
growing at a very quick rate there's
going to be a few learning objectives
today to this presentation um one is
understanding the importance of
data integrity what it entails what it
means to
a business and then also learning how
limbs and automation tools can
facilitate
good data quality and data integrity
finally understanding the ramifications
when you don't have a good system in
place to manage and maintain
a high quality and data integrity
and then we're going to take a look at a
few examples
okay uh data integrity what does it mean
why it's important who should care about
that and then to bring it to
into reality looking at some case
studies in the u.s
and india as well as in china looking at
opportunities and tools
for data integrity practices
again we're going to look at laboratory
information management systems
instrument integration as well as
enterprise integration with systems such
as sap or erp systems financial systems
positive id which refers to barcoding or
rfid
one-dimensional or two-dimensional
barcoding and today
more and more people are looking at
remote monitoring
devices rather than humans to
do the monitoring and just to save cost
and also to increase accuracy
now if you look at the term data
integrity it refers to generating
transforming maintaining ensuring
accuracy
completeness and consistency of that
data over its life cycle
and also compliance with the regulations
that impact that data
we see more and more organizations
moving away from paper and excel
sheets to electronic data and if we look
at the transformation packaging we can
see that
asia pacific in europe um europe
especially 62
are looking to move to electronic
systems asia pacific 57
and america is 41 so there's a real
strong push to moving data to an
electronic format
it just makes sense because not only
does it
produce higher quality data but it
reduces the carbon footprint you
eliminate
paper the data is easier to access when
it's electronically
available you're able to perform
analytics on that data whether it's in a
data warehouse or
a data lake so that
you can also apply artificial
intelligence to that data
now if we look at data integrity it can
actually be a state or a process
if we look at the process this typically
describes measures used to ensure
the validity and accuracy of that set
that's
contained within a database for example
error checking
or validation methods it can also be
referred to
the data integrity process now if we
look at data integrity as a state
this defines the data is valid and
accurate
one statistic that i saw was 40
of businesses report losing tens of
thousands
of dollars because of poor
data quality and that's that's not good
we need to fix that
as a as a country and analytical
laboratory managers
now if i look at data integrity as the
process there's domain integrity
the constraint on the individual value a
check constraint there's
entity integrity looking at the entire
table with primary keys and unique
constraints
there's referential integrity where the
data must exist in another table
so that if someone were to go into the
back end of the database
whether it's oracle sql server and try
to delete a piece of information
because that information exists in
another table they would receive an
error saying you're not allowed to
delete that data because it's
linked to this other information and
again
bad data is is not good for any
organization it's often the result of
duplication
or maybe there's missing information or
there's
incomplete information or also incorrect
information
i once worked on a project where a
client had
over 25 years of data to be migrated
and they had their data in a lens
unfortunately that limbs did not have
referential integrity so when we were
looking at all the data to be migrated
we found thousands and thousands of
orphaned records
that just weren't linked to anything so
there was a lot of dirt
data that needed to be cleaned before it
could be migrated
data integrity of the state these are
technical controls as well as procedural
controls such as standard operating
procedures
extensive use of sensors so that the
data can go into
a database electronically and these
could be thermocouples that are
associated with refrigerators
freezers incubators so that you have
continual launch and that monitoring can
go into a database
perhaps that average the maximum in for
each day
instrument integration so that there's
no need for someone to manually
copy and paste information from
the output from that instrument into the
limbs it can all go in electronically
and today many of the modern instruments
allow the lens to send a work list of
samples to be run to the instrument
the instrument can be loaded the
analysis can be executed and then the
results are sent back to the limbs
without any
need for any humans to retype any
information it's all electronic
and it's very fast and accurate
enterprise integration if the limbs
requires
for example specifications from a
database such as
safety those specifications when they're
updated
an sap can actually be pushed to the
limbs
on demand or on the schedule so that the
lens has the exact same information
that's in the master database of
specifications
another key is having educated employees
that understand
why things are done the way they are
done and
making sure that they follow the sops
later on temptation will give you
examples of what happens when sops
aren't followed
um i was joking with one of my sons that
we put mulch in the garden and before we
put the mulch down
we need to remove all the weeds and i
told them in my sop
you can't just grab the weed and pull it
because the roots are still there
you need to dig them out so that you
know
weeds are gone so when you take
shortcuts sometimes you have problems
downstream so it's really important to
have solid sops in place
and then make sure that everyone's
trained on them and then also
to verify that training through a quiz
or
some other means that they can prove to
you that they've understood the sop
and then also managing and maintaining
those training records
and having a company culture that
supports data integrity
quality management systems and also
that initiate correct transactions um
so that there's a continual improvement
and also these these electrical
environments they really require
management buying and support
throughout the project it's not just a
one commitment it's a
continual commitment
now many of you have probably heard of
the acronym
alcoa um
it um
it means that data is acceptable it
should meet certain fundamental
elements of quality whether it's
collected or recorded electronically
or on paper it's based on the 1999 fda
guidance
and decisions rely on data being both
attributable
legible contemporaneous original and
accurate
as companies get more and more automated
systems
with computerized systems the
fundamental fundamental alcoa principles
are satisfied by automatically generated
audit trails so having electronic
systems really
ensures that a lot of these controls are
in place
if we dive a little deeper you see that
alcoa is a
people it basically is asking who
acquired the data where the analyst
initials what's the
same is it legible can you read and
understand the data
i've often looked at female data it's
been collected by
either people working out at a plant in
manufacturing environment and oftentimes
the writing is very difficult to
interpret
like was that a seven or is that a one
so it's really difficult when you don't
have
good data that you're re-entering into
another system
um contemporaneous were the rockets
documented at the time of the activity
were the nice thing with computers is it
automatically
uh captures date and time stamps when
the action was executed
is it original is this the first
recorded observation or a verified true
copy
of that data point is
accurate this is the result scientific
valid and error free
so these are the key characteristics of
alcoa and then a few additional ones
that have been added over time are
complete which means
is all the data or including any reruns
that were done
linked to that sample point is it
consistent
are all elements of the analysis date
and time stamped
are they in the correct sequence is it
enduring
is the data recorded in a permanent
maintainable form
perhaps life cycle so is the data in the
databases that back
up has anyone checked the backup to
ensure that it's still retrievable
and then is the data available data is
ready for review inspection
or audit as long as that exists in the
database
so these are just a few things to think
about when you're collecting data
now the truth about data integrity
failures oftentimes
people think about failures and they
think oh there's a villain to blame
and in fact in a study that was
conducted by m dole
in 2016 presented in a workshop
um in london but what was found was that
80 percent of data integrity breaches
are unintentional
there is a link to performance and
business pressures
a lack of awareness or capability maybe
the
instrument no one turned it on
integrity is not completely divided into
the culture so there's not support from
upper management
and there's not really a environment
where people feel
safe to question perhaps it's adequate
inadequate processes and technology so
that really ties back to not having a
quality of di or data integrity
with the following actions though
company can begin to build a culture
where data integrity is at the forefront
and this is for education and
communication
making people understand what the
impacts of poor data
quality are understanding and detecting
risk and this is back to education when
people understand
some of the risks and why they're doing
what they're doing they're more apt to
follow
sops defining a strategy for data
integrity and technology
and this is basically back to training
um making sure everyone is aware of
technology that
is to be used how it's to be used as
well as
making everyone understand um
the importance of gathering high quality
data and if there's a problem to
if a result needs to be augmented
understanding the steps of that audit
establishing a governance structure for
data integrity
so all of these actions can really help
a company move in the direction of
higher
data integrity okay
let's look at some compromises in data
integrity
so if 80 of data integrity um
going back is unintentional that means
that 20
is intentional that's a fairly high
number
so if we look at some of the
unintentional ones human error
whether malicious or unintentional
transfer errors this is a lot of people
copying and pasting maybe pasting into
the wrong cell
bugs viruses malware hacking or other
cyber threats
are a continual issue for i.t
department compromised hardware such as
a device crash or a failure
even a disk crash physical compromises
two devices
since only some of the compromises are
adequately prevented through data
security
the case for data backup and duplication
is really important
oftentimes people will have a backup
database and they realize that their
database is corrupt or there's a problem
and they'll go to the back and that's
also corrupt so it's really important to
have checks in place
to ensure that you're protecting your
data and that it's
in the exact format that when that data
was collected
now if we look at input validation
there's some things that can be done
to make sure that banned data isn't
entered so with input validation with
the database
for example if you want to collect uh
date information
and you want the date information to be
month
month and then a year maybe a four digit
year
you can leave that many spaces on the
form and we've all seen this when we've
entered credit card information
into our screens for whatever we're
working online that's a great example so
you're not going to
get you may get raw information but
in the right format so it's just one way
to ensure that the data quality is
is maintained so you're not eliminating
all errors but you're eliminating
many error detection data validation to
identify errors
in data transmission there's also
electronic tools that can do text at
either end
making sure that if x number of
characters were sent
x number of characters were received
access control
this can be done with limbs and other
electronic systems
through privileges and permissions and
user roles
data encryption this is very important
when data is transmitted
from from the limbs into the for clients
that are using
software as a service environment so
that in transit the data is encrypted
at rest the data can also be encrypted
there's a lot that can be done to ensure
that data is protected
okay case studies this is
one area where i think it really makes
the data integrity come to life if we
take a look at a few case studies
the first one i want to talk about is
the one at a food testing lab
this is a delaware cheese company the
fda went into their laboratory
and they saw significant efficiencies
they had found
leaks in the roof that was actually
leaking
rain water on the equipment after the
process
and the impact of their equipment being
dirty and not
following um they're saying they were
following their sops
not actually following them it led to
contamination of the
the bacteria called listeria
monocytogenes
and fda founded on the surfaces the
impact that this had
were the total of eight people were good
five adults and three new newborns and
this is
the people they were able to find more
um so it's really important when you you
know have an sop in place
following tragedy in
san luis obispo from china this is
really
horrible in terms of its roots if you
look at this study um
there was a urologist in in china that
saw
four babies within 10 days with kidney
stones that's not something
normal for for infants and
he was very suspicious that something
was going on
and then very quickly a national
investor was unfolding and six minutes
died and over 300 000 babies
were sick because they were drinking
contaminated milk
so it was very interesting because
melamine was being used to increase the
um protein levels of the nitrogen pest
in the milk
so that it would look like it would meet
the nutritional requirements when in
fact
it was it was painted with melamine and
what happened was
um there were more than 100 lawyers that
were volunteering to represent the
families
and the chinese government declined to
take on any cases
and hear any individual suits instead
the chinese government the communist
party they basically
um decided to handle it and the
chairwoman
for san lu uh was given a life sentence
for failing to stop the production and
sale of the tainted milk
even after they were made aware that it
was dangerous
and there were several other executives
that received prison sentences between 5
and 15 years
a dairy farmer and a local supplier who
were actually
the ones that distributed the tainted
powder to the family were both executed
in late
2009 so it's it's very serious
um it's a very serious situation
what happened um national standards no
one
really wasn't required to test for
melanin no one had anticipated that milk
producers would doctor the supplies with
this chemical so it wasn't the test that
was normally done
the normal testing that was done looked
good everything passed
so this is a um an example of kind of
the villain where
things were added that shouldn't have
been added uh
there were this was uh the san lu only
began testing for melamine in late july
after realizing that pet food laced with
um melanin who killed pets in the united
states earlier
so it was very sad because they were
finding levels of high
2560 milligrams per kilogram
and the tolerable intake according to
the um sdga it was
six milligrams per kilogram and one of
the impacts is
you know ten plus years after the milk
tragedy
parents still don't trust any of local
formulas
to give to their children there's a
culture of
poor data quality there are two indian
pharmaceutical companies that actually
fired workers after the facilities
received the warning letters from the
fda
operators and technicians the number of
indian and chinese manufacturing
facilities from
2014 to 2017 who during an
fda site inspection reacted to auditors
requests by pouring samples down the
train
shredding documents removing memory
sticks and running away with them
so it's just really shocking what can
happen
when people aren't following the sops of
that organization
for each product and it's late
document shredding was noted by the fda
as recently as last year
in a warning letter that cited
deficiencies at a facility
and it's really sad because a lot of the
foreign facilities are manufacturing
um food products um
toys i mean it's just everything and all
these have
specific safety testing that they are
supposed to go through before they're
imported into the us
uh the quality department of one of the
big pharma over-the-counter drug
subsidiaries in the u.s whose manager
strong armed quality
analyst into failing failed batches this
department they were joking it was
called an easy pass
and then at the end six senior managers
were sued
um earlier to fund adequate qc testing
um and i thought of that saying you know
you can pay me now
you can invest in the tools and the
technologies a lend
employee training automation or you can
pay me later a fine of 22.9
million that's that's a huge settlement
that could have purchased quite a bit of
automation
um there was a case in 2014
there was a doctor william thompson a
psychologist at the cdc who worked on
the
um mmr vaccine measles
bella and they paper and they found that
there was
data where they had a subset of
african-american boys who apparently had
a higher
autism rate and he confessed ten years
later
after this occurred burning that data
and then coming forward and telling
telling what he did and he actually had
copies of that data so it's very sad
and then we don't even have to look far
if we just look uh past month or so
cdc 19 test kit
lab protocol failures at this
covid19 test from the cdc
so fda actually
audited the cdc and what they found
was that two of the eight these three
labs in atlanta
um they were creating the test kits for
covert 19
were sending ineffective tests to nearly
all the hundred
state and local public health labs
in the u.s that were faulty
and this resulted in contamination the
major problem was that the researchers
entered in less covenanted laboratories
without changing their lab coats
this resulted in the contamination of
tests
sent to public health labs making them
unusable
the cvc did not manufacture consistent
with its own protocol so
again someone wasn't following the sop
and this was from an fda spokeswoman as
a result of manufacturing problems with
the test
the cdc had to delay the launch of the
nationwide 19 detection program
for month and the united states lost
ground in the fight against covet 19. so
it's very serious when
when sops are not followed
now let's look at electronic data
integrity issues
files and these are just you know a few
that i found going through the
literature and some of these cases that
we've discussed
files were saying to a personal computer
they weren't backed up they weren't on
network
uh users are sharing passwords to save
money on software licenses
or there was just a culture in the
laboratory that
everyone could use a user's password
that had higher
permissions than another user password
the audit trail function was disabled
hplc integration parameters were changed
and re-ran
until the result passed now they did not
have an electronic backup
unsanctioned sample testing was labeled
such as demo
test blank or trial so that that testing
could never be linked back to any sample
inadequate access controls roles and
privileges were not configured properly
so there are cases where people have the
proper tools but they're not using them
in the proper way either due to
malicious behavior or lack of training
users logged in with a shared account to
change data
so there's a lot of you know just
because you have an electronic system in
place
it doesn't mean that you're
automatically going to have high data
quality and data integrity
there's a huge component to that is the
analytical
laboratory culture as well as the
training that's provided to the team
raw data integrity issues no raw data
for sample solution preparations
sample dilutions no raw data for sample
weight so there's nothing to trace it
back to
no raw data for sample preparation
standards
again there's no traceability
destruction of raw data that did not
meet specification
missing data rewriting data on
laboratory notebooks
without having any ability to audit that
or auditing that
invalidating data and re-testing without
a laboratory
investigation so many of these things
are just you know
bad practices and again not having a
culture of
data integrity now if we look at some
examples of data integrity issues if we
kind of dig deeper
data supporting we look at quality
control data supporting test results
were mis was missing
repackaged failed products without the
understanding of the impact of the
failure and then re-releasing the
product
the re-path product and then having a
good
test um result from one batch and using
that batch to release
others releasing product with null
contaminants
and in the sample area samples not
available yet
but yet there are results recorded for
those samples in the database
labels are partially labeled samples
poured down the drain
certain samples of known value were
saved for testing
a certain result look at microbiology
observed growth on a bacteriology plate
but yet no growth was recorded
to perform quality control on media
plates that were made internally so
you don't know if you saw growth or the
light
was contaminated and again if
it almost comes back to you if you're
not going to do a job right
don't do it oftentimes people take
shortcuts
really impact quality falsely and
incubator daily temperature readings
is available to laboratories now are the
automated things so that a human doesn't
have to go to each incubator in each
temperature every day and
manually record it on a paper log and
then maybe transcribe that into a
lens or another automated system these
messes can
after 24 7 herbs
we also talked about barcoding the
advantages of barclays and that it
increases accuracy and efficiency and
also
speed 1d barcoding as well as
two-dimensional
as well as rfid
all right electronic data integration we
talked a little bit about
instrument integration planning data
from contract laboratories
again if the data is available
electronically it's much nicer to take
that data
and just pull it into the lens so you
don't have to have anyone retype
anything
or copy and paste anything it's just
being automatically uploaded
and on that upload you can actually do
some data quality checking and create an
error log if anything is found
so typically instruments will put out a
number of file formats
comma separated value abbreviated csv
excel text or ascii xml
or i'll have web services that can be
interfaced with
or an api or database to database
the imports can be on demand they can be
on a schedule
and then you can also very quickly
import data from contract testing
laboratories into your limbs now
the advantages of instrument integration
there's a lot of business
advantages along with quality advantages
increased accuracy you're eliminating
duplication you're maximizing your
resources
remember everyone that works in the
laboratory is a knowledge worker they're
very highly trained so you want to make
sure that you utilize their brain power
for the things that you really need
humans for the chemistry
the roi is typically within nine to 12
months
most of the modern instruments can also
support two-way communication
and also giving employees the best tool
to do their jobs
results in higher employee satisfaction
if we look at data quality um you can
basically see the
entire life cycle where the limbs will
accept the data from
the instruments it'll help create
schedules
it'll allow people to create reports
there'll be dashboards available for
real time access to kpis and how the
laboratory is doing
um printers barcodes
being able to backup the data into the
cloud in addition to the
backup that is in the laboratory it's
always good practice to have an offsite
backup
and then also leveraging mobile devices
users can also leverage remote
monitoring which
are couples that can be placed in
refrigerators freezers incubate
humidity chambers laboratory rooms
and they can collect data 24 7
and this data can be actually in the
database server or sent to a cloud and
integrated with your lens
and then it can also be set up for
real-time alerts to either your
cell phone or your tablet automated
emails alert
that the temperature ranges that you
have set up
violated so that if there's a problem
you're automatically
notified so that you can rectify that
before there's a bigger problem
another tool of technology is being able
to have dashboards so that you can see
in real time
any issues that may be arising in the
laboratory
one of the dashboards can be set up look
at
the number of audits that each employee
is spawning so if you have one employee
that has
you know 10 times more audit than
another employee it may be something
that you want to investigate maybe it's
a training issue or maybe something else
is going on
so it's really nice to be able to have a
dashboard
each user can be set up to have a
dashboard
with the metrics that are important to
their jobs
and then one of the newer offerings is
software as a service
and it's interesting because now in
addition to having
all of your data in the cloud you also
have
a backup in the cloud so again there's a
lot of additional security the data that
it typically if it's with a
good provider when the data is going
from the laboratory
up to the cloud it'll be encrypted it'll
be also
encrypted at rest they'll be very tight
security in terms of the firewall
um so that when the data is accessed
it's very securely accessed
all right now let's take a look at a few
methods that support data integrity
what can the laboratory do to make sure
that they have good
a culture of good data integrity well
they can execute a risk-based validation
plan oftentimes people will hire
consultants to do
internal audits of their laboratory and
then they'll look at areas
in which they're vulnerable and then
they'll address those areas
they should also make sure that their
suppliers their partners their vendors
are iso certified so that
they know that they have a quality
management system in place
and they were audited by a third-party
agency that is expert in conducting iso
audits
they can examine the audit trails we
talked earlier about
creating an audit trail report so that
if there's one user that's spawning
a significant number of audits you can
talk with them and understand if it's a
training issue if there's a problem
with an instrument for something else
making sure that they have a
change control process in place that
everyone is familiar with
so that if changes are needed they're
documented
and people are trained on the new
process quality i.t
and making sure that it's included so
that they know which systems to back up
how frequently to back them up
that if they're systems that need
validation they can come in and assist
it's also very important to have a
business continuity plan
um if something's coming up such as a
pandemic
how are you going to continue working
luckily in our virtual world
many people can become remote workers
with the laboratories if you have
certain i know
many of the folks talk with have shifts
so there'll be
different people in the lab at different
times supervisors are able to review
reports online
because everything is very very
automated it's easy to go virtual
and then also provide data integrity
training for the team it's very
important that end users are trained
most people want to do the right thing
if they understand
what they need to be doing then it's
also important to make sure that
data that's archived and backed up is
also checked
does the backup
generate accurately oftentimes people
will be making backups for years and
then when they need it they find out oh
we weren't backing up everything that we
thought we were backing up
so that's another thing that's important
to consider
and in summary can be very dangerous and
it can be very costly
automation significantly enhances data
quality
it can eliminate transcription errors it
can really force
regulatory compliance and this is for
things such as keeping track of not only
employer training records but instrument
calibrations repairs it can prevent
data from going into the instrument is
out of
calibration an employee's training has
expired
it provides a unique identifier for each
sample
that is logged in it tracks each
container so there's a lot of control
over the information to ensure that good
data is
coming into the system along with
filters that can be put in place so
if you're looking for a date you
define how many placeholders you're
looking for
um you could limit since you have a
ph you can have an upper and lower limit
of
14 so no one can accidentally tighten
the ph of 21.
and then also ensure that the security
is in place the
users have been signed goals and
privileges and permissions to what they
can do within the system
oftentimes an analyst can enter and
review data but they're not allowed to
validate
the supervisor is often required to
validate that data
the cost of data bad data can really
hurt business it can shut them down it
can hurt their reputation it can put
them out of business
and it has lasting consequences and
causing harm
or even death so it's really important
when you're working in the laboratory to
understand
the impacts of the data that you're
collecting
and today we're hearing more and more
about data lakes
and analytics and artificial
intelligence
so it's more critical than ever that the
data that's uploaded
into these larger databases is of good
quality
thank you and have a great rest of your
day